whether you hate the guy or love the guy
Donald Trump is just something a little
bit different in politics you saw this
when he rolls up to UFC with Tucker
Carlson Don Jr Kid Rock and Dana White
and The Crowd Goes Crazy how strong that
team is making his way into the building
one of the bigger mix martial arts fans
I know president Donald Trump taking his
octagon side seat for UFC
[Applause]
[Music]
we got two title fights coming up at UFC
295 here in a matter of moments live
from Madison Square
Garden and president Trump will be here
to witness all of it four of the very
they're going crazy set to take imagine
Mitt Romney walking into the UFC
Stadium what wait oh who is that M okay
never mind let's go get a beer